there are actually way more environments
in Starfield than I realized Reddit user
Ultima star put together a bunch of
tours of different kinds of biomes so
the first one here is tropical forest
biomes where you're seeing like so much
diversity in color or so much more than
I realized like this is like kind of
Swampy looking this one's obviously a
lot drier it's more Rocky green bunch of
trees bunch of flowers and then we've
got like actual neon bioluminescent kind
of environments and things that look a
little bit more like Earth but that's
just the start here are a bunch of
different versions of Sandy biomes this
is like Sandy deserts on Earth this is
obviously very yellow dry but still kind
of grassy this looks cold but isn't
obviously places with sandstorms sort of
white Beach looking biome there are also
Plateau biomes which tend to be a little
bit more grassy there are also different
Frozen Mountain biomes like obviously
this one just looks like a bunch of
Frozen mountains this is on jemson a lot
more flat on Pluto with different rock
formations totally different color
scheme here even though this is still a
Snowy Mountain this one's obviously a
lot more iy looking and still foggy very
dense and there are different kinds of
wetlands as well with like totally
different color schemes